same thing on that it's it's the hardest
yield all right it's it's all internal
when he hits it other if you hold it if
you hold it it's going to go clack do do
you get it do you understand okay all
right so uh give me
a okay and I'm coming
around and I'm going to try for kiss on
his head he's going to do is stop H in
the sweet part of the Arc of my motion
boom
okay as I swing
that that is stick hitting sticks you
see
again that is an
external uh Clash okay there's there is
a slight rolling that'll take place as
you pay attention you he's coming around
you are boom a slight roll okay but it
won't be enough it has to be inside okay
so what do I mean by that it's the same
uh go back to beginning internal aspect
training okay so we start here and we
learn to root on the back foot and to
get out of the wrist and the elbow and
the shoulder so that it goes down to the
ground I have to release everything has
to be no tension in me okay later we
take that sense of no tension again and
we I can match him and get my adhesions
going okay or he could uh punch he could
punch and he could sit here and go the
exact opposite of everything I said or
he punches and it goes down there boom
pop and you get that stuff going do you
understand what is it I got to release
tension in order to release tension I
have to to reconcile fear in order to
reconcile fear I must let go of the self
I must release okay so as I'm coming
around and I go and I see it no there's
tension in my body inside Again release
of the self does not have a physical
form do you do you doesn't it doesn't
matter what my body is doing okay it's a
spiritual thing so as I come around
no I'm going to stick to him no missing
it
again no I have to
relax
no continue to form
no there we go you see relax and I I let
go of the grip so you could
see that it's not necessary there's an
adhesion that's happening you get it and
so the Joe's stuck do you feel do you
feel it it's stuck okay he tries to
drive back onto me here's my Thro he's
going to lose
boom so he has to try to withdraw I
follow he comes back and I'm adhering
and there's my opening
okay it's inside it's
inside hence internal it's not outside
okay try your best